auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Musik]
kühne pläne cornelia breit schmiede und
jean-marie suter wollen in marokko eine
kleine feriensiedlung bauen
neues leben neues glück die familie
händler übernimmt den schwedisch
lappland eine hotel und campinganlage
und auf und davon in ein neues abenteuer
mit kamelen zieht die familie blum durch
das australische outback
[Musik]
noch haben nicht alle den richtigen
platz gefunden für die reise in ein
neues leben
familie henzler zieht es in den hohen
norden nach schweden
mit dabei auch die gute seele der
familie und brian
gefährte der kinder janne und chemie
[Musik]
tastatur maus branchen mag in schwedisch
lappland nur gerade 20 kilometer vom
polarkreis entfernt offen max und seine
jasmin ihr neues glück zu finden sie
übernehmen eine hotel und campinganlage
jetzt ist das natürlich für mich die
große überraschung
jasmin hatte die anlage im internet
entdeckt als ihr mann max den kauf per
handschlag besiegelte weil sie jedoch
mit den kindern in der schweiz
max war schon immer vom norden
fasziniert seine ehefrau hingegen
tochter einer italienerin zog es
ausschließlich in den süden noch schnee
[Applaus]
es brauchte eine gemeinsame reise und
auch jasmin war von skandinavien hell
begeistert
und torlos wir sind gut drauf sind die
schönen strecke des kontinents absoluter
traum sind sie dadurch fehle
doch nun ist schluss mit ferienparadies
schweden soll die neue heimat für
familie henzler werden
das ist wichtig
das war mir nicht auf kriegsfuß stehen
mit wie tickt natur
ursprünglichkeit und
was mir den ring kampeter auf dem hof
sicher diese war mit zwölf mann kann
nicht weiter vor dem gremium springen
diese dürfen aber trocken feucht ob und
was sie wollen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
in kölliken im kanton aargau wandern
auch zwei aus jedoch ohne kinder denn
die sind schon lange selber eltern noch
ein letztes mal hütete marie sutter
seinen enkel aber
bald schon ist der großvater auf und
davon
der 60-jährige wandert nach
[Musik]
assets bricht muss ich sagen
ist nur einer von sieben enkeln und noch
vieles hin zu erwarten denn so marie hat
tatsächlich einen haufen kinder er ist
vater von vier töchtern und wir sind nun
dritter
[Musik]
aber zwischen gesunde pflanzen die zeit
ist reif für neue abenteuer an jean
marie seite ist cornelia breitschmid vor
kurzem haben sie geheiratet ihr
marokko abenteuer nimmt im netz bereits
gestalt an
mit einem kollegen kreiert cornelia den
webauftritt für ihre kleine
feriensiedlung in
der nähe von seoul ihrer einem ort an
der atlantikküste
russland kauft ist oliver braun sieht
aber wesel hat das machen tracking abete
vergesst mir werden die
gäste des restaurants
und so bei mir denn die [ __ ] wirke das
sieht man jetzt das ist der kranke zwei
hektar wald macht ist der murano meisten
bruchsteinen
das projekt das muss ganz alles
amerikanische behörde keine fehler
administration und dem klang mal diesen
moment warten termin bis das projekt
und sie hat schnell das ist
[Musik]
wiedersehen mit sabrina blumen aus
daraus töchterchen nayla hat einen
holzsplitter eingefangen
diese monster
die familie blum ist bei auf und davon
keine unbekannte
vor sechs jahren schon haben wir sie
beim auswandern begleitet
es war die sehnsucht nach dem einfachen
leben welche die familie blumen damals
2011 nach kanada ziehen dies in
einer gottverlassenen gegend bezogen sie
eine blockhütte
sie ernährten sich von dem was die natur
her gab
und mama sabrina krug in dieser wildnis
ein kind unter dem herzen
im frühling kam töchterchen nahla zur
welt
[Musik]
im sommer boten die blums trekkingtouren
zu pferd an doch die kanadischen sommer
sind nur kurz das einkommen gering und
es gab noch einen weiteren grund in die
schweiz zurückzukehren
[Musik]
und das ist natürlich sehr ungünstig für
sie wenn mir da so wird klar wenn also
anders groß aber das ist nicht das ziel
sondern darum gehen das ist alles
generell im leben viel kreis bis den
weiß- oder mehr gefangen das alles eben
so hat alles in grund
keine pferde kein kanada mir nur die
abenteuerlust die blieb
[Musik]
und wenn ein abenteuer mit pferden nicht
mehr möglich ist muss ein anderes tier
her
wir planen mit kamel und faden durch das
australische outback ziehen sie nehmen
sich neun monate zeit dafür dass sie
halt daneben erwartet
und ich möchte mal eine gute chance
wunsch dass man das wenn trotzdem muss
man
intensiv wie familie zieht und genießer
mit der doch die erste frau
ich möchte schon gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was nicht mit soll ins neue leben
verkauft familie händler über das
internet
heute wechselt ein wickeltisch für 50
franken den besitzer
die leute gewinnen
die auswanderung ist für die familie
eine chance max wird in schweden
komplett neu beginnen der projektleiter
wird gastronom
erst vor kurzem hat sich max von einem
schweren burnout erholt
[Musik]
rouven untergang nicht eigene firma
gründete auf
beratung für supply chain management
sowie ganz
rational wie sie denn vorhanden
richtig heftig
gebuhlt
nachdem ihr slogan zieht
und
den sexy er ist
[Musik]
also da nicht viel buchcafé steckst du
dir
und mir sind die fragen und das
ist das mindeste zu haben
unterstützt von der familie und mit
hilfe einer therapie fand max langsam zu
seiner alten kraft zurück er war bereits
sein leben wieder in die hand zu nehmen
und ihm eine völlig neue richtung zu
geben
das schicksal hat diese zornig fehlt
ein täglicher spaziergang half max ins
leben zurück und an diesem ritual hält
er bis heute fest
[Musik]
eine vitrine voller tabakpfeifen die
müssen mit nach marokko
maries große leidenschaft ist das
pfeifen drechseln sind der dax anfang
mai 120 wenn
andere sagen strengt aber
zwar packt er heute schon alle pfeifen
ein verschifft werden sie jedoch erst in
einem jahr
dann nämlich sollte das erste haus der
feriensiedlung stehen
und dann kommt auch die ganze pfeifen
werkstatt nach marokko
jean marie ist ein vielseitiger mensch
er war briefträger und alten herd hat
ein männerheim geleitet war im
strafvollzug und im asylwesen tätig
es braucht besondere mut in eine
weltregion auszuwandern welche nicht
sehr stabil ist
[Musik]
er hat aber nicht dass das jetzt wie
eine arabische
lernen
cornelia zieht am gleichen strang vor
sieben jahren funkte es zwischen den
beiden am arbeitsplatz
die juristin war leiterin des
sozialdienstes
einer ihrer 150 mitarbeiter
es waren marokkanische flüchtlinge die
sie zu einer ersten ferienreise nach
marokko inspiriert hatten
in der schweiz
und an die welle welle selbst dahin
unterschied je nachdem zu
deiner marokkaner wo ist mein geschenk
gemacht haben die immer sehen was
das ist eigentlich der grund sie einmal
jetzt könnte wollte und dass eben
begeistert ich sie was man den vorrunden
die
gastfreundschaft die unkompliziertheit
die bescheidenheit und das immer noch
mal aber und hanna humala
gm städtisches gut und so ist das
projekt entstanden zur zeit habe mache
bis zwei mal
und zwar in
ihr gemeinsames schweizer projekt
hingegen sechs bretonische klein schafe
lassen sie zurück die tiere kommen auf
den hof von cornelia haß patenkind ein
letztes mal schneiden sie die klauen der
schafe
da sind sie dabei rutscht einen gängigen
lebenslauf hat auch cornelia nicht
zuerst eine kv-lehre dann eine
weiterbildung zur sozialarbeiterin und
mit über 30 packte sie noch ein
jus-studium an
nun ließen unstimmigkeiten am
arbeitsplatz die 49 jährige ihr leben
überdenken und dabei packte sie ihre
alte abenteuerlust wieder
diese lust auf neues hat auch ihren
ehemann jean marie angesteckt kurzerhand
bis er sich frühpensionieren
[Musik]
auf der madrisa oberhalb klosters hat
markus blum seinen letzten arbeitstag
der gelernte hochbauzeichner und
schneesportlehrer verfolgt ebenfalls
keine klassische berufskarriere um seine
träume zu leben jobbt er als
hilfsarbeiter
extrem flexibel sie und muss
das ist
wirklich am liebsten machen aber wenn da
sind wir denn der weg zum ziel ist dann
muss das alte soße
und markus hat glück denn seiner und die
lebensziele seiner frau sabrina waren
schon von beginn weg deckungsgleich
[Musik]
nur wer bereit ist abschied zu nehmen
kann zur abenteuerin werden diese
erfahrung macht heute amira sie hat
ihren letzten schultag während der
nächsten monate wird die zweitklässlerin
in australien die schulbank drücken
auch die mama hat sich ins klassenzimmer
geschlichen
[Musik]
es ist die letzte stunde wir machen
jedes kind überreicht am ihrer einen
ganz persönlichen wunsch
und wir hoffen natürlich dass alle
wünsche in erfüllung gehen ausstrahlen
[Musik]
und auch der papa verabschiedet sich von
seinen kunden
ein tag vor abreise in einsiedeln
herrscht das chaos noch ist nicht alles
fertig und gleich beginnt der bei april
[Musik]
die schinken gipfel sind noch kalt doch
die ersten gäste schon da
auch die mama von jasmin ist da sie ist
einst von italien in die schweiz
eingewandert
der vater machte als koch karriere in
england verwöhnte er blaublütige und
stars später betrieben er und seine frau
in der schweiz jahrelang ein eigenes
restaurant
es ist überhaupt die
persönliche wirtschaftliche hier jeder
schicken oder zurück
es feiern viel mehr gäste als jasmin und
max erwartet hatten der tag der
chaotisch begann endet mit einem
fröhlichen beisammensein
[Musik]
während zweier jahre haben die blums ihr
australien abenteuer vorbereitet
endlich geht's los doch etwas fehlt noch
[Musik]
die zeltstangen und
ohne süßigkeiten gehen amira und nara
nicht auf die reise
der vater lebt ins auto was es wirklich
für die zeit in der wildnis braucht
[Musik]
und also innerhalb erfolg
laura scott erfährt die familie zum
flughafen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
letztlich
das betreffe aber nur halb so viel spaß
sagen
mir ist noch nie im herbst
[Musik]
an einem regnerischen herbst tag nehmen
die marokko auswanderer abschied von
kölliken und ihren liebsten
auch schon maries erste frau bringt die
mutter seiner kinder ist da
und natürlich auch die kinder samt
anhang und enkel
nebst sechs eigenen kindern adoptierten
sohn harry und seine damalige frau noch
zwillinge aus indien
mit
lustig also
nicht
schaut sich im ratenkauf würde ich nicht
lang
soll er
begeistert ich an einer mitteilung
die einen dank bin ich ziemlich sicher
die produkte hat das sehen wir in
eintracht mit euch in marokko strafe
dann können wir einig dass sie daher
nach hause sind
gut
[Applaus]
maries ältester sohn tut sich schwer mit
den plänen des vaters
[Musik]
das abschiedsfest geht zu ende
[Applaus]
vermutlich auch
tipps
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit einem gemieteten lieferwagen will
max den henzler haushalt nach schweden
hochbringen
jasmin lädt den familien buscemi scott
hilft dir dabei sie waren als erster los
max folgt nach
[Gelächter]
dass wegen der kinder wollen die beiden
frauen die 3000 kilometer lange reise
gemütlich angehen
auch kater ist reisefertig sind wurde
sie zur unterstützung
ja
noch schnell den wohnungsschlüssel in
den briefkasten und es kann losgehen
auch max hat einen copiloten freund
roche im gegensatz zu den frauen wollen
die männer die strecke so schnell wie
möglich zurücklegen
[Musik]
währenddessen macht jasmin einen
zwischenstopp in nebligen unterland in
neuheim holt sie und brown ab um das
sensible tier wurde hektik der letzten
tage zu schützen hatte sie ihn in einem
tierheim untergebracht
zurück in einsiedeln vermisst max
bereits seine frau
ich
könnte jetzt ganz vielen erinnerungen
zweites problem aber trotz dicker finger
er schafft es
in schweden angekommen wird katzer noch
für viel mehr aufregung sorgen
[Musik]
alles eingepackt endlich kann es
losgehen
[Musik]
am anderen ende der welt
die familie blum ist mitten im
australischen outback angekommen
ihr ziel ist hocker ein kleiner ort dem
bundesstaat south australia
wie sie aber
[Musik]
einfach spannt sie mir ali
hallo
[Musik]
wer will
findet
auf dem hof der familie ließen die blues
wilde kamele trainieren
sind die kamele einmal ausgebildet
wollen sie mit den tieren für drei
monate durch das outback ziehen
die adresse müsste stimmen
[Musik]
doch wo sind die besitzer des hofes
musikalische werke
präsentieren
[Musik]
nach einem bewegenden abschied sind
cornelia und chambéry in ihrer neuen
heimat angekommen
[Musik]
die beiden brauchen kein taxi zu deren
von freunden abgeholt
das nicht konnte habe ich ja das nächste
aber nicht ganz
[Musik]
ihre freunde das sind die beiden
marokkaner lassen und aziz und
der deutsche die die
auf früheren reisen haben sie sich
kennengelernt
die fahrt geht vom flughafen marrakesch
ins rund 120 kilometer weit entfernte
hinterland von ist
[Musik]
alle meine kinder und meine enkelkinder
meine schwiegertöchter und söhne sind
zum abschied gekommen aber wir haben
fast nicht geweint
eines meiner kinder wird schon im
november zu besuch kommen
[Musik]
dass der rudelführer in marokko kein
rudel mehr haben würde das wussten sie
doch dieses so fremde land hält für die
beiden schon bald einige überraschungen
bereit
[Musik]
in australien sind die blums noch immer
auf der suche nach ihren gastgebern
wer bist du
wir suchen pohl ist das dein vater ja
ich weiß nicht wo er ist aber er hat mir
das natürlich sollen herumführen
in der nächsten sechs monaten der die
familie in diesem wohnwagen leben
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
im hohen norden schwedens
seit ankunft der fähre in göteborg sind
sie durch gefahren max roach und aisha
angeordnet
sagt kilometer gemacht
zurückfahren
ist doch so
da ich es
st
[Musik]
als schon ein
die
[Gelächter]
schweizer kommen weiter
das gibt es gar nicht dass du jetzt auf
haut und
ich weiß wie schnell man
konnte ganz nach villingen
[Musik]
johanna schopper
schnell
schloss eingefroren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge von offen davon
große visionen in marokko
doch im büro der architektin holt sie
die realität ein das projekt stockt der
großeinsatz für katze in schweden
jasmin sie zum ersten mal ihr neues
zuhause
das ist strom
erster schultag für die blumenkinder in
australien
[Musik]
und die eltern trainieren zum ersten mal
kanäle
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobile
versicherungen und vorsorge